AI never sleeps and this week has been absolutely
insane. We have a new realtime video generator
that can run on a consumer GPU. We also have
a real-time texttospech generator that's super
lightweight. It can run on any CPU or even
just your mobile phone. Bite Dance continues
to cook this week by releasing an incredible
state-of-the-art AI model. We have an open-
source thought to text AI. This can analyze your
brain waves and figure out what you're thinking.
This open- source AI can generate videos that
are 2K or even 4K in resolution. Alibaba releases
their best model yet, Quen 3.5. Google also drops
their best model, Gemini 3.1 Pro. Plus, they also
released an incredible and free music generator.
This AI can turn your prompt into a full 4D scene.
We have some ridiculous humanoid robot demos and
a lot more. So, let's jump right in. First up,
Alibaba releases their most performant model yet,
Quen 3.5. This is a multimodal model that has 397
billion parameters. But when you use it, only
17 billion parameters are active, so it's quite
efficient. And like the top models out there,
this is especially good at reasoning, coding,
agentic abilities, and multimodal understanding.
The really awesome thing is this has a million
token context window. So this is like how much
information you can fit into your prompt at once.
And a million tokens is among the largest in the
industry. You can fit like over 700,000 words or
a medium-sized codebase or over an hour of
video into your prompt at once. And if you
look at these benchmarks, it's very impressive.
So, it's really good at instruction following,
also graduate level science questions as well as
agentic abilities. And also, it's really good at
document recognition and video reasoning. So like
overall it's as good as some of the top closed
models out there like GPT, Claude, and Gemini.
The awesome thing is because this is multimodal,
it doesn't just have to work with text, but this
can also take in images and video. So you can just
upload an entire video and ask it questions about
the video or even get it to create a PowerPoint
presentation like this. Or here's an example of a
racing game that it has coded up. This is actually
the most impressive 3D racing game I've seen so
far. like the other models aren't able to get this
level of detail. And of course, it's also great
at front-end design. For example, we can get it
to create a sunscreen product website. And here's
the result. And of course, you can also link this
to OpenClaw as the model to use. And then you can
prompt it to do stuff via WhatsApp or Telegram.
So, here's an example of that. This is also really
good at spatial awareness and understanding. So,
if we upload this image and we ask, is the
telephone booth on the left or right side of the
yellow van? This is actually a quite tricky photo
because the yellow van is pointing north. So,
the telephone booth is actually to the right
of the yellow van even though the rest of the
cars on this lane are facing south. So, it has
to reason a lot, but eventually it does end up
with the correct answer. Or you can also upload
this maze and get it to find the shortest path
and it's able to pull up Python and code up an
algorithm to find the shortest path. And here's
our result. A really cool thing is you can even
get it to solve sudoku puzzles which a lot of
top models aren't able to do well. So you can
just upload this image of a Sudoku puzzle and
then it would proceed to solve it for you. The
awesome thing is they've actually open sourced
this. So if you click on this GitHub repo and
you scroll down a bit here, it contains all
the instructions on how to download and run this
locally on your computer. Now note that with 397
billion parameters, this is quite huge. This is 87
GB in size. So you're not going to be able to run
this on most consumer devices unless you have your
own data farm. But that being said, this is one of
the best open- source models you can use right
now. Even if you can't download this locally,
you can also use this online for free via their
Quen chat platform. So on this model dropdown,
you can select these Quen 3.5 models. Anyways,
if you're interested in reading further, I'll
link to this main page in the description below.
Also, this week we have an open-source Genie 3. So
this is called Anchorwave, and this can generate
interactive world videos. In other words, this is
a video where you can press the WD or arrow keys
and move around this 3D world. So, it just takes a
starting initial frame and then you can generate a
3D world from that where you can move around. Now,
currently for one iteration, it can only generate
81 frames, which is roughly a few seconds,
but you can iterate this multiple times to create
a longer video. The really impressive thing is it
can maintain consistency and realism over a long
period of time. Here are some other examples for
your reference. Notice that this is much better
than previous interactive world generators in that
this one actually preserves a memory of the scene.
So even if you look away and then you look back,
everything remains the same as before. And then
here are a few other examples. And as you can see,
it doesn't just have to work in a first-person
view. You can also upload a thirderson perspective
like this. And it can also generate a third person
video of this character moving around. The key to
anchor weave is that it uses a special technique
called local geometric memories to generate the
video. This means it breaks down the scene into
smaller parts and uses these parts to create a
consistent and realistic video that preserves
the overall 3D configuration of the scene. It
also uses what's called a multi-anchor weaving
controller to help combine these parts coherently
and generate a smooth video. Now, if you compare
Anchorwave with other 3D scene generators, notice
that it's just a lot more coherent and detailed
compared to the other methods. So, here's one
example, and then the ground truth is on the lower
right. Anchorwave is actually very similar to the
ground truth or here's another example for your
reference. The awesome thing is if you scroll up
to the top of the page, they've already released
the code to this. So, if you click on this GitHub
repo, it contains all the instructions on how to
download and run this locally on your computer.
Note that currently this initial model is based
off of an older video generator called Cogvideo X,
but they're also planning to release a one-based
example in the future as well, which should be
better in quality. Anyways, if you're interested
in reading further, I'll link to this main page in
the description below. Next up, this AI is is very
useful. It's called Tiny A by Coher Labs. And like
the name implies, this is quite a small and open
weights model which can help you translate stuff
or respond to you in many different languages. So
this is incredibly tiny. This is only like 3.35
billion parameters. So this is even small enough
to run on consumer hardware or even your mobile
phone. And this model knows over 70 languages. So
that's the base model. And then they fine-tuned it
further to create this tiny AA global model.
And this can support 67 languages. Here are
the 67 languages that are supported by tiny AA
global from five regions of the world. So here's
a benchmark on multilingual generation quality
comparing tiny AA with other similarsized models
across languages from all these different regions.
And as you can see on average, tiny AA performs
better. This is also incredibly efficient. So in
this graph the y-axis is the generation quality.
The higher the better. And then the yaxis is the
number of parameters. So the smaller the better.
Ideally, you want to be in this upper left corner.
And as you can see, tiny aa is over here. Now,
you can try this out on hugging face for
free right now. So, it looks like this. Here
are some examples for your reference. Here's an
example of a Spanish prompt. And as you can see,
it answers incredibly fast because this is very
tiny. Or here's another example where the prompt
is Arabic. And again, it's able to answer you
incredibly fast. Or here's a Chinese example. And
here is an example where we get it to translate
a sentence from Basque to French and it's able
to do this very well. The awesome thing is this
is open weight. So they've already released the
model on hugging face. And here you can see that
at least for the tiny AA global model, this is
quite tiny at only 6.7 GB in size. So this can
fit comfortably on most consumer GPUs. Anyways,
if you're interested in reading further, I'll
link to this main page in the description below.
Also this week, we have an incredibly lightweight
texttospech generator called Kitten TTS. This
is incredibly tiny. Here it says it's under 25
megabytes and it's only 15 million parameters,
not even a billion parameters. So, this
essentially allows you to even run this
on just a normal CPU or even just your mobile
phone. You don't even need a GPU to run this.
And it's so lightweight that you can even run
this in real time with just mediocre hardware.
Kitten TTS. The super tiny and expressive open-
source models are back with an upgrade. This time
we're launching three tiny models, an 80 million,
40 million, and the smallest one with just 14
million parameters. Our smallest model is less
than 25 megabytes and can run on minimal hardware.
This clip was actually produced by it. These were
built with love by a tiny team of kittens. We're
working on packing Frontier Intelligence into tiny
models. Check it out on GitHub and connect with us
on our Discord community. In fact, they already
released a free online demo on hugging face for
you to try this out. So, for example, let's try
these two tricky sentences. And here we can choose
from the smallest model, the medium-sized one, or
the largest one. Let's just go with the default
medium-sized model. And then here we can choose
from a list of different voices. Notice that right
now you can't clone your own voice. So you can
only choose from their preset voices. And then
here you can choose the speed of the generation.
And that's pretty much it. So let's click on
generate. And here's our result. The record
producer refused to record the band's new single.
The wind was too strong to wind the kite string
around the spool. All right. So it's not bad
for a super tiny 40 million parameter model. The
awesome thing is they've released all the models
already. If you click on the largest one, this is
only 80 megabytes in size. though even this can
fit comfortably on like a CPU or you can even fit
this just on your phone. And then the smallest one
is only 25 megabytes in size. Super tiny. And then
down here it contains all the instructions on how
to install and run this locally. Anyways,
if you're interested in reading further,
I'll link to this main page in the description
below. Next up, this news is pretty insane. So,
this company is called Talis and they just
unveiled this chip which is incredibly fast
and efficient. It achieves 17,000 tokens per
second. If you don't know what that means,
here is a chart comparing the tokens per second
or basically the output rate of this Talis HC1
chip compared to the industryleading chips out
there. This includes Cerebrus or Gro or even
Nvidia's state-of-the-art B200 which is all the
way down here. So, this is like 40 times faster
than Nvidia's state-of-the-art chips. And get
this, not only is it faster, but it also costs 20
times less to build and it consumes 10 times less
power. So, how exactly does this work? You see,
an AI model is basically a neural network. This
is currently made of code and this code lives in
software. For example, a transformer could live in
this PyTorch code. Now, this software needs to be
powered by hardware in order to run. But because
of this disconnect between software and hardware,
it's not as efficient. But here, what Talis has
done is they've basically hardcoded the AI model,
specifically Llama 3.1, onto the chip itself.
So this AI model that lives inside this chip can
now respond to you in real time as fast as the
speed of thought. You don't even need to wait
for the sentence to complete. And I think this
would be the future of AI models. We need custom
hardware that's designed specifically for these AI
models so that they can be hard-coded into these
chips. This design merges memory and computation
together all on just one chip which unifies the
entire system. You don't need any big cooling
or complicated components. And this helps cut
down the costs significantly and also make it way
faster. But here's the main problem I have with
this. So this chip is built specifically for Llama
3.1. It's not going to work if you add DeepSeek
or Quen or another AI model onto this. So at least
currently the technology is that you need to build
a chip specifically for each model. But I think
this is definitely going to be the future where
we have AI living directly in hardware instead of
software and this is just the beginning. Anyways,
if you're interested in reading further, I'll
link to this main release page in the description
below. Also, this week we had Lunar New Year.
So, of course, China hosted their annual spring
festival gala event. And here they showcased some
insane abilities from the Unitere G1 robot. This
is a huge improvement compared to last year.
Here you can see some clips of the rehearsal
or training of these robots as well as the live
performance. And as you can see, it's able to do
some insanely acrobatic stuff. I mean, these
robots are able to jump like two to 3 m into
the air, executing full flips or even multiple
sequential flips. Some of them can even perform
continuous single leg flips and also run up a
wall and flip. This is crazy. This is actually
really impressive because jumping and flipping
requires some explosive actuator torque that
pushes the absolute limits of robotic hardware.
And the hardest part actually isn't even the jump,
but the landing. The robot must calculate its
mid-air orientation in real time and anticipate
the exact moment of impact and then instantly
absorb the massive kinetic force through its leg
joints to prevent, you know, bouncing or slipping.
So, not only does this require explosive power,
but also incredible balance, but as you can see,
they've programmed the Uni Tree robot to do this
very well. In fact, they even have one robot
intentionally wobble and act like it's drunk
and then falling on its back. But within a split
second, it was able to spring back up like this.
That was actually intentional. And then here
we have some demos of multiple robots using
these nunchucks, which again is actually very
hard. So this fundamentally alters the robot's
center of gravity and momentum with every swing.
So the robot needs to constantly recalculate and
recalibrate these forces to remain balanced.
And then here's another demo from Unree of
the rehearsal and training process of these
robots. And this is another really impressive
feature. You can see right now this swarm of
dozens of robots are controlled by one system.
They need to rapidly move around into these
tight coordinations to spell out specific
shapes or characters. Controlling one robot
is hard enough, but networking dozens of them
requires this centralized swarm intelligence
system with near zero latency. So, here they're
showcasing how you can now deploy not just one
robot, but multiple robots in large synchronized
fleets for like mass industrial or logistical
operations. A pretty crazy demo. Also this week,
this AI is very useful. It's called Louv, and
this can generate ultra highresolution videos. So,
you just need to enter a text prompt, but as you
can see, this can generate some really detailed
and highquality videos. It's much better than the
other top open- source alternatives we have like
LTX2 and 1 2.2. So, here's an example of a bee on
a flower. And this is just a 2K example. I'm also
going to show you some 4K examples in a second.
As you can see here, even like each strand of hair
on the bee is visible. This is how detailed the
video is. Or here's another example of a lion fish
swimming in coral. And again, note how detailed
this whole video is. Super impressive. Right now,
those were just some 2K examples. Here we have
some 4K examples. Look how crisp and clear
everything is. You can even see the ripples of the
water if you look closely. This isn't just like a
fake 4K video that's actually 1080p. This does
actually look like 4K. And then here's another
superdetailed example of this row of camels
walking in the desert. Here's another example for
your reference. Again, you can even make out the
minute details of the waves hitting the shoreline.
Very impressive. Now, if you compare this with
other video generators or upscaling methods,
notice that by far this new model outperforms the
rest across all these different benchmarks. Now,
at the top of the page, they do have
some buttons for a GitHub repo and data,
but these don't link to anything yet. Hopefully,
they will open source this for now. If you're
interested in reading further, I'll link to
this main page in the description below. I've
been covering a ton of video generators lately.
There's Cling 3 and now Seed Dance. And just to
let you in on a little secret, there's going to be
more crazier models coming soon. If you're feeling
overwhelmed from better models coming week after
week, then Higsfield, the sponsor of this video,
would be a great option. It brings together the
best image and video generators all in one place.
You can use the best available video model. Cling
3, and of course, the legendary Seed Dance 2.0
will be available as soon as possible. One of my
favorite things about Higsfield is their preset
templates library. you can just grab something
right out of the box and start creating. Some
popular ones include the skin enhancer preset or
this clothes swapper or this relighting preset.
There are also a ton of camera movement presets
which you can easily use to make your generations
even more cinematic. Plus, they have a new Vive
Motion feature which allows you to easily generate
motion graphics. Simply start with a prompt and
you can optionally add a reference image or a
video. Hicksfield then generates a professional
polished motion design right away. If you're
looking for one unified platform that has all the
best image and video generators, so you can easily
create assets without switching between sites,
Higsfield is one of the best options to use.
Try it for free using the link in the description
below and stay tuned for Seed Dance 2.0. They're
going to be the first to release it when it
comes out. Next up, this AI is pretty wacky. So,
it's called Zuna Thought to Text and apparently
it can scan your thoughts or basically your
brain waves and translate that into what you're
actually thinking. Here are the specs. This is
a 380 million parameter BCI foundation model for
EEG data. So, EEG stands for electrophalogram and
this is basically a way to measure electrical
activity of the brain using small sensors or
electrodes attached to your scalp. And so this is
basically an AI model that's able to analyze and
translate this EEG data. Now, when you connect
these electrodes to your scalp and generate
these electric signals, here is what the EEG data
looks like. And this data by itself, it's really
hard to analyze what exactly this is. Typically,
these signals can be very messy and noisy. Plus,
the electrode layout could be different between
different subjects and different places. Plus,
you could have some channels missing. Anyways,
all this data is really messy. So, the point of
this Zuna model is to dn noiseise this EEG
data. In other words, clean it up and also
reconstruct any missing channels and also predict
new channel signals based on current data. Now,
currently, this does not directly turn EEG data
into text. So, it's not that good yet. It can't
just magically interpret what you're thinking
from this graph. The point of this currently is
to clean up the data or reconstruct missing data
and also add higher resolution to this data. So
think of this as like the first open-source
foundation model for brain signals. This is
just the start and the long-term vision for
this is to eventually of course just take
this raw brainwave data and convert it into
text on what the person is thinking. Anyways,
the awesome thing is they've released the model
weights already. So, if you click on this GitHub
repo, it contains all the instructions on how to
download and run this locally on your computer.
Note that it's actually quite tiny. So, the
model is less than 2 GB in size, so you can
fit this comfortably within most consumer devices.
Anyways, if you're interested in reading further,
I'll link to this main page in the description
below. Next up, this AI is super powerful. It's
called Audio X and this is a unified model
that can generate audio and music from a ton
of different inputs. You can input text, images,
or even videos and get it to generate audio from
that. So, here are some examples. First of all,
here are some text to audio examples. So, you
can easily prompt this to generate sound effects.
Here is Thunder and Rain during a sad piano solo.
Very nice. And then here are
some ocean waves crashing.
Now you can add more specific details to your
prompt. For example, a machine gun fires twice
followed by a period of silence, then the sound of
waves and surf. Let's hear what this sounds like.
And it followed this very well. Or
here's another example. Fireworks
burst twice followed by a period of
silence before a clock begins ticking.
Very cool. Now text to sound effects
is just simple stuff. Here we also have
some text to music examples. So here is
a suspenseful scene in a haunted mansion.
That does sound pretty scary. And then here's
an uplifting ukulele tune for a travel vlog.
The quality is mediocre. You can
probably get away with using this
for some background music. Or here is some
smooth urban R&B beat with a mellow groove.
Now in text to music, that's just simple
stuff. We already have some really good
quality music generators out there. So,
that wasn't too impressive. But in addition,
this can also take in video as input
and generate audio from that. So,
here's the final generation of the video
plus its generated audio stitched together.
Notice that it's able to actually detect the
exact time when there was a cut in the video
and then generate the appropriate audio
for that. Here's another tricky example.
Or here's another example.
Now, in addition to inputting a video,
you can also input audio and get it to
repair certain sections. For example, here
if we have this original audio clip where
the middle part is deleted. Let's hear
what this sounds like first. Thank you.
All right. So, there was some silence in the
middle. Well, we can just inpaint this middle
section with some brief speech followed by loud
applause and cheering. And here is our result.
As you can hear, it's quite seamless. You
can barely tell like when it's actually
filling in this part. Now, similarly,
instead of filling in the middle,
you can also use this to extend an audio clip.
So, for example, here is the original audio.
And then let's get it to continue this. The prompt
would be action-packed orchestral
music. And here's the result.
Now, those were just some examples. The
audio quality isn't great, to be honest,
but it's really impressive how it's able to
take in so many different types of inputs.
This is truly a unified audio model. And if you
compare this with other competitors, notice that
this one by far outperforms the rest in terms of
not only performance, but the amount of abilities
that this has. It can do pretty much everything
from text to audio, text to music, video to music,
image to audio, inpainting, etc., etc. The awesome
thing is they've released this already. So if you
click on this GitHub repo, this contains all
the instructions on how to download and run
this locally on your computer. This is quite a
small model. So, the model size is less than 6 GB,
so you should be able to fit this comfortably
with most consumer GPUs. Anyways, if you're
interested in reading further, I'll link to this
main page in the description below. Next up, this
AI is quite interesting. It's called Veto Pix, and
this is a quite unique way of editing images. So,
here's how it works. It would basically convert
your image into vector shapes like this and then
you can edit each vector shape individually and
then from that it would reconstruct the final
image like this. If you do want to like really
control the shape or composition of certain things
in the image, then this might be a good way to do
so. So here's another example where we can stretch
out this mountain and set it to the exact shape
that we want and regenerate the image from this
vector reference. Now, this doesn't just have to
change the shape of stuff. You can also select
a certain element and then change the color of
the vector and it would apply the color change
like this. Here's a cool example where we can
convert this image into a vector and then move
the rose vector somewhere else. And here's our
results. So, this is really good for like moving
or repositioning objects in a photo. The cool
thing about working with vectors is you can also
add additional vectors on top of your image. So
for example, we can add this vector of sunglasses
onto this and then here's what we get. Or we can
also remove anything from an image. For example,
we can remove this toothbrush vector and here is
our result. Or you can just add any other image
onto this vector render like this and it would
still work. It can seamlessly add that object
into your photo. Now, given that we already have
Nano Banana Pro and also Quinn ImageEdit and other
state-of-the-art image editors where you can just
simply edit any image you want with a text prompt,
I think this method might be overkill unless you
really want to microedit something in the image to
be of a certain shape or position. But if this is
of interest to you, then at the top of the page,
it does say the code is coming soon. Currently,
this doesn't link to anything yet, but if you
are interested, I'll link to this main page in
the description below for you to read further.
Next up, this AI is really cool. So, this
can generate 4D scenes, in other words,
3D videos or simulations just from a text
description. So, it's basically a chatbot
where you can just enter a prompt and it would
create an entire 3D scene which you can edit
further in Blender. Here's an example. Here we
have a breeze stirs through the autumn forest,
gently swaying the entire tree as leaves dance
in the wind. And here's our result. Here is a
full 3D scene that can move over time. Or here's
another example. Here's a 10-second time-lapse
capturing the transition from warm pre-dawn to
sunrise followed by a midday sunlight through
a green canopy, golden late afternoon light,
etc., etc., and it's able to generate this
3D scene of a time-lapse very accurately. Or
here's lush green forest with heavy rainstorm.
And then here's a vibrant underwater scene with
a translucent jellyfish, etc., etc. Pretty cool.
Here's another example where we have some chopped
trees burning fiercely in this dark forest. Now,
of course, this can also generate indoor
scenes with different actions. For example,
here we have this tall ceramic cup which tips
on its side, spilling water and flooding the
tabletop as it flows toward the edge and drips
down. Or here's another indoor example. Here we
have a cozy bedroom with warm lighting. Notice
that everything in the scene is 3D. You can edit
any object further using some 3D editing software
like Blender. Or here we have a brown glass bottle
rolling slowly across the living room floor. If
you click on this GitHub repo and you scroll down
a bit, it seems like they will release the code
to this soon. And then here it contains all the
instructions on how to get started. Anyways, if
you're interested in reading further, I'll link
to this main page in the description below.
All right, next up. This AI is pretty crazy.
What if I told you that we can now get realtime
video generation on just a single RTX 1590? Well,
this AI called Monarch RT does exactly that. This
can generate true realtime video at 16 frames per
second on just a single consumer GPU, specifically
the RTX 5090. Now, I know this is still a pretty
high-end GPU, but hey, at least you don't need
like a data farm to run this. It's still pretty
affordable. And by the way, speaking of the RTX
5090, I'm actually doing a giveaway of this. So,
make sure you watch to the end to learn about the
full details of the giveaway. Now, if you compare
this to another acceleration method called flash
attention, notice that Monarch RT is almost four
times as fast. Now, you might think that with such
a fast generator, you might see some degradation
in quality, but that's actually not true. So
if you compare this with dense attention which
is like a video generation at full quality with
the same prompt here it says it's able to reach
like 95% of the quality of this. So at the bottom
is this new monarch real time and as you can see
the quality is very similar. Here are some other
examples for your reference. The awesome thing is
at the top of the page they've already released
the code to this. So, if you click on this GitHub
repo and you scroll down a bit here, it contains
all the instructions on how to download and run
this locally on your computer. Anyways, if you're
interested in reading further, I'll link to this
main page in the description below. Also, this
week, Google releases their best and latest model,
Gemini 3.1 Pro. Now, this is just an incremental
upgrade. It's just 3.1. It's not Gemini 4,
but nevertheless, this is incredibly powerful, and
it already tops independent leaderboards, as you
can see here. Plus, the price is extremely cheap
compared to other closed source competitors. And
the awesome thing about Gemini is it's multimodal.
Not only can it understand text, but also images,
audio, and video. Now, I already did a full review
video on it, so I'm not going to repeat too much
here. See this video if you want to learn more.
But in addition to Gemini 3 Pro, Google also
released an insane music generator called LIIA
3. This is completely free to use. You can use it
right now on the Gemini platform or app. So on the
Gemini app, simply click on create music and then
here you can just enter a prompt to describe your
track or you can even upload an image to guide
the generation. So here's an example where I just
uploaded this image of a barbecue and then asked
it to make a song based on the image and then it
composed this. Let me play this for you. Sun's
going down, the grill is hot. Flipping burgers for
the whole dang lot. Got that blueg grass blasting
on the speakers loud. So raise them up. We're
feeling proud. Yeah, this is what it's all about.
Good friends and good times on a Friday night.
Everything is feeling right. Yeah, feeling right.
All right, so that was the song for this
image. Let me know in the comments below
if it fits the image. Or here's another
example where I uploaded this image and
then asked it to make a J-pop song about
this image. And here is what I got.
Going
racers.
precious time.
We are the winding road racers.
All right, so it wasn't too bad, but there you go.
Here's a high energy J-pop example based on this
image. Now, this can do a ton of other styles.
So, for example, here is some retro synth wave
tonight. Oh, the neon dreams.
It seems
or here are some Hindi lyrics in pop ballad style.
Amen.
Make me
or here are some Spanish lyrics in funk
and city pop style. Fore! Foreign! Foreign!
And then here are some other
styles for your reference.
Oh baby, it's been a long cold winter walking.
The wind is up and the sail is set. Give away
the finest crew. City lights are bleeding through
the rain. We're dancing in the memories behind.
Here are some other examples of songs
generated from different images.
Pain salt on your skin in the snow.
Everything
is fine. Now, like I said, this should already
be available on the Gemini platform or app. You
should see a button down here to create music.
Anyways, if you're interested in checking this
out, I'll link to this main announcement page in
the description below. Now, last week, Bite Dance
releases a monster of a video generator called
Seed Dance 2.0. This is by far the best video
generator out there. It's not even close. But
this week, they've continued to cook by releasing
another state-of-the-art model called Seed 2.
This is a large language model. So, just like the
top models out there, this is especially good in
terms of multimodal understanding, reasoning, and
agentic capabilities. Here are some benchmarks for
your reference comparing CE2 Pro on the far left
with the top models out there, including Claude,
GPT 5.2, and Gemini 3. Here are some benchmarks on
visual reasoning. And as you can see, C2 actually
outperforms the other closed models in most cases.
And then, same with motion and perception. For
instruction following, it's not as good. It's like
on par. And then same with real world tasks. Now,
because this is so good at visual understanding,
we can upload this image and get Python to plot
this out and make it as similar as possible.
So afterwards, it under goes some deep thinking.
And then here is the final result. It looks very
similar to the uploaded image. Or here we're
basically getting C 2.0 to autonomously click
and do stuff on a computer. So here we're getting
it to operate this free CAD platform to edit and
manipulate 3D objects. And as you can see, it's
actually doing all of this autonomously step by
step. And as you can see here, it has done like
almost 100 steps sequentially. So this is really
good for like long horizon tasks. Now, I've been
scanning some independent leaderboards to see if
they've added seed 2.0 yet, and at least for LM
Arena, they have. So in terms of text, Ced 2.0
ranks number five. And then for vision, which C
2.0 is especially good at, this ranks number four,
still behind Gemini 3 and 3.1. Now, currently,
you can only use this via this Volcano Engine API,
but if you're interested in checking this out
further, I'll link to it in the description
below. And that sums up all the highlights
in AI this week. Let me know in the comments
what you think of all of this. Which piece of
news was your favorite? And which tool are you
most looking forward to trying out? Thanks
for watching and if you enjoyed this video,
remember to like and subscribe. And if you've
made it to here, I've got a treat for you. I'm
partnering with Nvidia to give away an RTX 5090
GPU around their GTC 2026 event. With this, you
can easily run AI tools locally on your computer.
Here's how to enter. Simply click the link in the
description to register and attend at least one
GTC 2026 session, which will be on March 16th to
19th. You can attend virtually or in person. Here
are some of my favorites. Jensen Huang's keynote
is an obvious one, but this one on humanoid robots
at scale as well as this one on openw world models
are also on my watch list. Again, make sure you
sign up for GTC using the link in the description
below. And then afterwards, fill out the form
and you're good to go. It's totally free to